oh you
[Music]
can perfect
[Music]
all right what's up guys i am thomas
dobasiola welcome back to the dope as
usual podcast we're here to talk about
life drugs accomplishments problems and
everything in between today guys uh
this guest i wanted to bring on to you i
know 90 of you know who this person is
heard the story heard the tales but for
everyone out there i want to educate you
guys on
the people that i feel
more of pave the way for you to not be
in such trouble
if that that's a good way to go or you
know what i mean uh but here we go guys
it's free with rick ross the real rick
ross thank you for coming through thank
you for having me thank you thank you um
i'm just going to start off straight
into it like i said this is to me this
should be a full length brand new
i know michael williams played you
before right
yeah he did he did right yeah yeah i did
an interview today about his death
that's so sad i was just talking to him
about it yeah he was he was cool he was
a cool dude i mean
out of all the people
that has
benefit often of my story
had something to do with my story
he was the coolest one out all of them i
mean
um
i mean he gave me an option you know he
came to me he was like
and i got this big movie role
and
i was like what is it he was like it's
kill the messenger
they want to give me your role and i was
like
why didn't let me be a part of it
exactly i didn't know
yeah you know i'm saying why am i
hearing this from you
and he was like
i don't know he said but i will do what
i will do i'll go back to the producers
and the directors and i'll tell them you
want to be a part of it and uh he did
and a couple days later he called me
back and he was like
they say they don't have nothing in the
budget for you
and i was like
don't play the role
oh
and uh you know i went home and i
thought about it and he told me what a
big role
he felt that this was going to be for
himself
and
you know i thought about it i was like
[ __ ] man you ain't never been no hater
you let the brother go ahead and just
exercise his rights and he also told me
about
uh
the way they wanted to portray my
character you know totally out of
character i mean even the way
he got him to play it was still
out of my character
at least the way i see myself
yeah yeah and you know a lot of times we
see ourselves one way and
the world see us in a different light
you know but uh
i try to keep
a realistic
perception of myself
um
i want to be close to what i think i am
yeah you don't want to be misrepresented
yeah yeah especially on a scale like
that but but some people you know some
people they're pieces of [ __ ] and they
think that they're great you know
i don't want to be like that you know if
i'm a piece of [ __ ] i want to clean
myself up you know i want to get myself
right yeah i never
i i never just
want to be one of those people who just
allow myself to be
just a freelancer you know just to do
whatever no matter
how [ __ ] up it is or how good it is
you know i i want to to to have
some type of measurement on what i do so
um
when
they
was talking about the role it was just
wasn't me you know
the guy was boastful and
cloud loud talking [ __ ] and you know i
mean that's not me i'm i i'd rather be
the guy who nobody sees
you know who pushes the button and
nobody know who pushed the button of
course
dressed in the old navy clothes
the guy you never underst you never
would that's it like i met a lot of
those people and those ones that last
yeah and that's that's what i that's
what i want to be you know like
um
i got two books out now you know like i
i went from being
when i found out that it was important
to learn how to read
i learned how to read
you know better yourself uh uh your life
was on the line right my life was on the
line
so but but that's what we're just in
life you know and that's
one of the things that i
consider why i'm successful is because
i'm always looking to up
myself up my performance
yeah so you're not one of the people
that think about how does everybody else
think it's how do i feel about myself
absolutely i care i care absolutely
nothing about what you think about me
that's the only way to be and and and
even if you totally don't like me
i'm not mad at you
so because that's your opinion
and you have a right to base your
opinion on
whatever it is you base your opinion on
you know that's none of my business you
know how you come to your conclusions
you know because those are your
conclusions and not mine yeah so plus
you i've never gone to sleep and thought
i wonder what they're thinking about me
never in life some people do though and
that i mean that's that's their whole
life i think some people the whole life
is impressing other people so they can
feel that
yeah but i'm lucky i guess you're in a
lucky personality because we could be
like that and i would hate it
could you imagine growing up with that
mentality is so different but that's why
you got to dress a certain way you know
you got to talk a certain way yeah walk
a certain way you can't go over here you
can't talk to these guys because they
don't like them
you know so yeah no not the path so he
came at you respectfully and said did he
do the so he ended up saying i'm not
going to do the role if you don't have a
budget for you he didn't say that
okay we didn't get to that you know uh
we left the meeting you know we went sit
down and had dinner and he bought me
dinner
you know at that time i was i was broke
that time i just gotten out of prison i
hadn't been out of prison long and
shouting 10 11.
yeah something like that yes it was
early on um
and um
i i was just like
the rapper had already took my name you
know and and used it and
and then do jack [ __ ] for me you know
didn't offer me a car or a job so for
everyone i know you're saying because i
i know the story but for a lot of the
fans out there you're in jail you're in
prison federal prison and rick ross the
rapper decides to go william roberts
that's his name william all right we're
going to address him as william roberts
never i know you probably most people
don't know his name because he doesn't
admit his own name you know well when he
came out i i remember going i've heard
that name before and that's not the same
person i know that because you know just
being a kid just growing up around
because i'm from uh i don't know if you
know california too well but i'm from
like by fresno merced area yeah that's
real grimy and [ __ ] so i'm gonna say it
is oh you do yeah hey
you're one of three people ever ever
said this um well you know i used to
chase weed
chase weed chase weed what do you mean
what does that mean
chase weed follow it around wherever
they grow it that's where i go oh to buy
it out or something you had to buy it so
you should sell weed before you started
doing anything else no no i saw weed
after i got out of prison oh okay so the
the legal route yeah no not necessarily
legal not yet and not all the way legal
at one time
at one time i was i was i went to the
black market you know uh um
when when
when i first got into marijuana
i i got in there from a necessity you
know i was going around selling my book
and i could barely pay my rent and i was
like what the [ __ ] i'm selling all these
[ __ ] books i'm working long hours and
[ __ ] ain't working out going to all the
events and all that yes so uh when i got
off parole one of my partners was like
man i'm going to this cannabis event you
ought to go with me
i was like i don't want to go to that
cannabis [ __ ] i don't want to be around
those [ __ ] cannabis people
[ __ ] are having me selling cocaine
again
that's how i'm thinking right i'm like
because you i mean even though
i'm a different thinker but i've still
been brainwashed with that [ __ ] that
we was a a gateway drug
i mean really i believe that even after
all this after everything i've been
through and then i had to really like
look at myself i'm like [ __ ] you started
selling cocaine for you and ever saw
weed
man that way you did it a whole
different route man
so you know i had to do some some some
soul searching and then eventually i
went to the event with him and
and i just fell in love with the with
the community that was the la one right
san bernardino say but guy that's the i
have a picture if i'll find it i have a
picture with you um probably 2014.
you came to my booth
uh i can't remember who introduced me to
you
and then you had your book we took a
picture of your book and you were
showing it at the booth but that was
so so many books there i was i was
strong when i left that thing that night
i was like it's the right hey
this is where i want to be
supportive community man yeah it truly
is especially if you've done something
that people uh respect like
getting yourself out of [ __ ] jail
that's just a huge thing
every person i know has been to jail or
prison over this weed [ __ ] at one time
or another so
seeing someone prosper out of it even
though it's not for the weed it's just
it's like [ __ ] yeah what can i do to
support you huh yeah well you know i
mean if if you look at
the amount of people who have
got in trouble for drugs
it would be staggering you know probably
in the hundred millions you know for
sure i would say 75 of everybody in
jails for drugs right yeah at least 60
70 65 70 percent
it is disgusting and and and you know
really when you when you think about
when you think about drugs you're
thinking about really a victim in this
crime
yeah you're doing it to yourself yeah i
mean it's too it's too grown people who
consent you know like uh
you got some weight for sale yeah you
want to buy it yeah i'll sell it to you
yeah it was just the government wants to
tax it it's rooted in for-profit prison
though that's what it's i mean [ __ ] as
soon as you get to what private prison i
mean
the whole prison system is set up
it should be redone i mean you shouldn't
be allowed
to lock people up and benefit on from
locking them up exactly you know judges
should not be allowed to own prisons
that's unreal you know prosecutors like
recruiting prosecutors should not be
allowed to own prisons because it gives
them an incentive to to
incarcerate longer
and incarcerate more people
and i think that that's part of what the
system has has been doing you know with
the privatized prisons and you know you
can't even invest
in this system if you're not in in law
enforcement
wait you can't invest at all no not in
not in not in some of these uh private
prison corporations you can't invest
unless and you're in
in law enforcement you know you got to
be a judge police officer that's just a
gang
at that point absolutely that's a gang
absolutely legally
that's astonishing i didn't know that i
didn't know that
yeah yeah i didn't know they had a few
of them
they may have changed it now
but
when i was in prison there was
prison
corporations wagon hut
that you could not invest money in
unless you was
a a guard or wow or a deputy or a
prosecutor or a judge so they want you
on their side before they take your
money to make sure absolutely absolutely
i guess if i'm in that piece of [ __ ]
mind state that they're in i understand
why they did that but still pieces of
[ __ ] for doing that absolutely that's
terrible this piece it's a piece of [ __ ]
move at the lowest level of arresting
somebody for weed and now you owe me 500
bucks for this ouija hat
like what what
am i actually supposed to be learning
through having to chop you out 500 bucks
over this [ __ ]
20 sec yeah it's getting better though
man it's getting better we just
we just getting more lean yet i feel it
is it is yeah but but still it's still
[ __ ] up the way they tax it you know
the way they give it out the way they're
giving out the licenses
you know that's [ __ ] up because
they're putting these high
prices on some [ __ ] is like the grass
that grow in your front yard you know
what i'm saying that [ __ ] is no
different it's a weed yeah you know
uh why are you charging [ __ ]
three thousand dollars a pound for this
[ __ ] you know
they just want that tax money man
i understand it's the government they're
gonna [ __ ] you no matter what at least
let me keep a little more money thirty
percent forty percent you gotta pay on
taxes just to buy weed let alone you're
selling it how much they're gonna charge
you for that then packaging then
quarantine then the delivery the
distribution charge
it's almost like you're working just to
make it just to make them pack money
back it is it is
a little unreal people would be amazed
you know i go into a lot of dispensaries
and and i hear the owners talking about
how they're not making any money you
know it's really just
almost like being glamorous you know oh
look i own a rolls royce i own a
dispensable shop you know salts for but
you know they're not really making it
there's a few who really got the this is
um
yeah most of them grow it themselves the
only way man other than that you're
paying taxed on top of tax on top of
middleman on top of distribution
it's impossible but the government made
it that way for the licenses like you
said so they the rich stay this rich
stay rich get their licenses make more
money and then monopolize the whole
thing and buy out the little guys and
it's over and george hi yeah because
then what you go back to the street oh
yeah i've been buying black market weave
my whole life man i don't give a [ __ ]
well the black market's going to keep
them honest
yeah you know it's going to keep the
legal market on us and until
um
the legal market come in line
with what's going on i mean you know
[ __ ] you had to go in and pay
i mean even even with my weed and i
don't grow so i have to buy my wheat
from other people
and [ __ ] eights is seventy five
seventy dollars
seventy seven dollars with [ __ ] eight
i'll be like what the [ __ ] i hate to
even tell people how much i know it
makes you feel like i'm not getting over
on you either i'm barely making [ __ ]
money you know i go there with my book
and and and they'd be like damn rick
your age for 77 bucks i want to buy some
but i only got 30 bucks 40 bucks and i'd
be like buy a book man
so before we get too crazy into the weed
topic i want to bring everybody back
just just to
get along the chronological the story is
where did you grow up at like i grew up
in south central born and raised not
born no i was born in texas tyler texas
i moved out here when i was around three
or four so i'm in la all the way oh so
you're all yeah you're from here yeah i
don't know i don't know texas
if you didn't go to middle school or
high school you're from wherever you're
at there so you're from california i'm
from california first first school i
went to was uh
uh west vernon
elementary nice i started there and um
after that i went to a catholic school
and watts
um got kicked out for fighting you know
actually like the fight
oh [ __ ]
you know guys
grab my marbles and run i'm gonna run
you down oh hell no i'm taking my
marbles were serious oh no no you
talking remember that that was like my
sack that's me too i used to keep it
like a
basically an ounce of weed i don't know
what all marketers were talking about
you never played marbles like the poison
all the stuff remember the steelies and
crack full oh [ __ ] that has never
happened he got excited damn remember
you got people's taking back to a kid he
got excited for real i just got all
crazy guys so the marbles used to be
serious every morning everyone i got the
confetti i got the cat eye and you know
it's kind of like gambling too
yeah like i'm gonna take your [ __ ] by
the end of the day you put yours over
there
if i hit yours it's mine yeah it was a
serious thing the little asian kid
uh he had like five of his cousins and
they would [ __ ] take everyone's [ __ ]
they did that spider [ __ ]
they were good at it man squatting down
marbles was a serious game i remember
that damn i haven't thought about in so
long yeah she's gonna love it too i
loved it i loved it uh did you play
sports as a kid yeah yeah i played
everything football baseball basketball
i was i was you know i'm pretty good
athlete uh in high school i played
tennis you know i i didn't get big so
stuck with what you can get yeah yeah so
i started playing tennis
around 12 and and
and i'm thankful for tennis you know
tennis probably kept me out of gangs
really i don't think i've ever heard
anybody say that yeah yeah yeah tennis
kept me out of gang because i was on the
tennis court all the time so i didn't
have time to
who had you out there just yourself or
was it like
an adult true huh well when when we
first started it was uh this guy come to
the court and he's betting us that we
can't hit the balls in the box
that's how it started a couple of my
friends took a serious
and i followed them you know into the
game you know i saw it with the
sweatsuits and rackets and free tennis
shoes this is what they're giving away
tennis shoes 70s right yeah 70s 70s
tennis before john mackerel before like
it got popular mcenroe was there and
macklemore was okay sorry that was the
80s was [ __ ] was [ __ ] super like crazy
in south central that time
uh
man gangs was just really like kicking
up so you you saw it from nothing so
full-blown yeah i remember when the
first gangs
i remember the first day the crips came
out elementary school it was like came
to your school
yeah they surrounded our school
it was probably like two three hundred
people elementary though
yes
they were waiting for a kid
no they i mean they didn't do nothing
they was just
like hanging out oh i thought you meant
like they surrounded the school like the
storm like for [ __ ] elementary they
didn't they didn't they didn't do
anything they was just there you know
you're a little kid seeing this he was
like what the [ __ ] who was that and it
was like oh them the crips
that's that new game
whoa but they were on some like
community
it was different at first already yeah
yeah it wasn't it wasn't the the beat em
up you know robin you know that started
coming on later on in in in in the in
the in the uh
in the in the story
yeah yeah i didn't know that that's
unreal to see the birth of a new gang
that's still here
they are so big now that it's
overseas
they got over this
overseas yes i didn't know that
in canada
so how did you avoid that i always
wondered that like how did you you
played tennis you need that like
back up or whatever well when when when
i first saw him i wanted to be a [ __ ]
oh as a kid
yeah when i was around 11. i mean yeah
they're all they're all it's the
community thing like that's my brother
that's my brother that's my home that's
my family and then you know i grew up
without a father too
that's a big thing too and my big
brother wasn't living with us he was
living with my dad
oh weird so i didn't have a brother
what's the age difference on that we're
seven years different oh he's your big
brother then yeah he was my big brother
yeah so no so i was kind of
i mean the homies was my big brothers
you know those were the guys i looked up
to those the guys i wanted to be like
you know so when i found out they were
in the gangs
i would have been a gang too yeah you
know they played football and you know
they taught me how to play football and
basketball and baseball and i was like
[ __ ] maybe they're teaching me how to
gang bang
as a young looking back on that isn't it
so weird to think like
i just wanted to belong at some point or
something yeah you know when when when i
was sitting in prison and um you know i
started to write my book and
uh tookie williams i don't know if you
know yeah uh originally one of the
original crypts right original crips
when
they were getting ready to kill him
uh my life flashed by you know and i was
like wow
i felt so lucky
because it was a time that
had
tookie allowed me
to hang out with him
i would have yeah he'd be right next to
him yeah i would have been right there
so
when when you see
him getting executed then you're
thinking to yourself that
i could have been in that same position
yeah
you know
it was just
um
a stroke of luck that this guy came to
the tennis courts that day and
kept his rackets in our hands
and
i fell in love with it
you know i i went head over heel over
tennis and um
saved my life
wow
something so small and insignificant you
think just playing around helped you
yeah well you know one of my well two of
my friends that that i grew up with went
to elementary school with i hung out
with every day
they turned the crips
one just did 35 years just got out
and the other one did that in 40 years
oh my goodness
he's been there since you guys were kids
18 years old
dang damn near 60 yes no 60 not damn
near 60.
wow man your whole life's just gone like
that
so when when you think about that i was
like wow
lucked out
man big time you know uh at least
you know i went to prison but at least i
went to prison for
something you can possibly get out of
one day and i knew what i was doing you
know like i perfectly was fine with
trying to make some money
for my family and
if i happen to go to prison for doing
that
so be it
you know i was willing to to make that
sacrifice
but you know when when
these guys went
to prison for probably robbery or
you know
probably got 200 bucks 150 bucks always
that way 60 bucks you know maybe
um
it's it's a big difference you know i
used to make
my last two years a million dollars
every day and
some days as much as three million
dollars you know
so um
i enjoyed
it was worth going to prison for is what
you're thinking would you mind no it
wasn't worth it no i wouldn't i wouldn't
do it over never trade it back no no it
wasn't worth money it's not worth 20
years no no time um
i'm saying if you're in there like at
least it wasn't 60 bucks like this
robbery at least i was making something
exactly at least i saw
was it hard for you to do anything like
with the money was it like i got too
much that's one of the questions i had
too like all that cash i would imagine
how do you go and buy it i know people
like cash oh yeah yeah i mean
you know you got you i mean you got to
fill out the people who you're doing
business with yes you just don't walk up
you know to to to mr
wrong at you know goody touchu who's
who's never did nothing in his life
which i don't know who that is
someone might play like they never did
but anyway you you know you pick the
people who you go and that's another
problem too though you know that that
that drug dealers have is that
they're dealing with shady people
yeah when it comes into the hard drugs i
feel
like the weeds more of like hey this is
my hippie client this my other guy sells
100 packs like he's nice well now the
weed is
mellow like that but before we was just
as bad as cocaine
[ __ ] really like it was just as scary as
to go buy a hundred packs as it was
buying bricks yeah they'd rob you the
same way they'll rob you now 400 pack oh
for sure yeah i know that so so
yeah so so
the the the danger element was still
there the cops were still hard on it you
know so if the cops is hard on it that
mean that the robbers
know that you can't call the cops oh for
sure and if they think you can't call
the cops then they feel like
anything that they want to do to you you
know with the with the with the
with the whole thing about
being a drug dealer not being able to
snitch
you know because if somebody robbed you
call the police you could be labeled a
snitch forever or if they shoot you
you know you can't tell because you'll
be able to snitch so it's a lot of
elements that went on not only with the
cocaine and heroin but with the weed as
well you know you could be a snitch and
weed too if you if you go to the 100
yeah i used to like from like 15 to 22 i
was selling that's all i did was sell
packs and then i started making this so
i had to stop selling weed but
a hundred pack is the most i ever at one
time was nothing like
making 30 racks is nothing compared to
what'd you say a million dollars a day
yeah i want to [ __ ] quit i was i used
to be a pizza driver so i used to drop
packs off while i was drilling pizza
so that nobody ever got pulled who pulls
over the pizza guy nobody nobody did you
have any instinct to stop like i'm
making this much i need to get out now
yeah you know you do um
because you weren't always making a
million dollars though no no no no not
always you know i started off i start
off with with 50 50 bucks you know the
first rock my boy gave me was a fifty
dollar ride someone handed it to you my
boy he told me to see if i could do
something with it oh [ __ ]
yeah that's good
that's how you started it's awesome
where were you i know you know exactly
where you were at when he goes here
because that's your life changing yeah
where were you at when you were doing it
like in someone's house outside i was i
was at his house
wow in south central
uh right off of washington and arlington
um he just come back from college you
know he played football at san jose
state
and he was like man i got the new thing
and i was like what is it man give me
something i need something you know like
i'm down on my luck i just got arrested
for stealing cars how were you
19. oh you're kid you're a kid okay 19.
yeah i was young i didn't know i was
green you know i thought i knew
everything but i didn't know [ __ ]
if i would i'd have been making a
million dollars a day right then
uh but yeah he he he uh i took my first
snort that day you know oh first time
i'd ever snorted cocaine
uh any drug i never saw i never even saw
a drug before really i was a tennis
player man man you're so rare
you know what i'm saying i was cool
though
one of those green green [ __ ]
you know like i don't know nothing i
remember
and i talk about in my book the first
time i go to the street races you know i
never been to the street races i was a
tennis player right you were sheltered
almost go to bed at 8 o'clock i
sheltered myself good though you know i
was doing that to myself because i i
wanted to be a tennis player i wanted to
get out of the ghetto you know i wanted
to buy a big house for my mom were you
aware of venus and serena was that in
your mind or no one they wasn't they
were probably not even not even alive
stupid ass question
i was just thinking like you were way
before that that was before you had
anybody to really look up to like yo
that is the star athlete
actually
oh so you did have somebody okay we had
our dash
um
so
i was green man you know and here i am
all of a sudden i go from that to
to first
you know my boys take me to the street
races and like damn i never saw a low
rider before i've been living in la
19 years wow and i never saw a low rider
before at least i never recognized them
now you know what that what it is so now
i'm at the street races i'm like oh look
at that paint job look at that girl he
got in there
i want i want one of them the car and
the girl yeah
that's that infatuation man see you see
that like that older dude just
that's what i want all of them got one
of the pretty girls in the car and they
got the music blasting and they
hitting their lips and i'm like oh my
goodness look at that 64 that
[ __ ] is dope
homie where you get this at man how you
get this
he's like
you really want to know i was like yeah
man i want one of these
how can i get one
take my number call me the man damn like
that yeah come by the house tomorrow
i'll go over there they put a snatch bar
on my hand a what a snatch bar i never
heard that before what is that they pull
the ignitions out of cars with them
it's a dent puller oh that's what they
use to snatch the mission out of the car
i just know that [ __ ] yeah yeah oh no
the things that you got
yeah i know what you're talking about
you ain't never seen it but you know i
know i didn't know that's what it was
called
hey you did it like a pro though yeah my
dad my dad mechanic and [ __ ] so
my whole family mechanics but yeah yeah
so that's what they do that's how that
that's how they stole it no these two
cars like that [ __ ] you got to be
careful i got an old ass car yeah that's
how they stole the car so i went
i went from there to stealing cars now
no that's what the guy was doing to get
that car he was partner
yeah
yeah that's a dangerous game man so now
i'm a bonafide car thief
still playing tennis or no
a little bit i'm i'm about tired of
tennis making money basically gonna get
me a girl
you know what i'm saying i want me a
girl now [ __ ] that house outside the
hood
i stay in mom's garage
so um
i start selling cars every night
every day every day every night what are
you looking for when you see a car just
uh wheels a wire and bulbs
you know no i mean like what are you
looking for like
that's the one i'm gonna take what is it
what are you looking for the wheels
oh wheels
the wheels you know you got some of them
thousand dollars two thousand dollar
wheels oh i'm gonna get them
you know they're gonna bring four
hundred dollars for sure
damn so you talking about here i am 19
years old
in south central l.a
i can go out at night and make two three
hundred dollars in one night that's a
lot of [ __ ] money back here and now
uh so so the dudes who who i went and
talked to with the with the car
he go to jail
that's your guy right yeah but i i i've
been running with him for
six seven months you could take it by
yourself
so i didn't saw everything you know you
didn't taught me the whole game you know
and and what i learned from tennis is to
be observant
you know a tennis player has to be
observant you know you have to study
your opponent
you want to watch the way he twists his
hips because you can tell kind of where
he's going to hit the ball yeah the way
he twitched
so from doing that i have become very
very observant
so when he goes to jail
i know all the body shops that he's been
selling all the parts
so what i do is i double back i'm like
oh you know my boy in jail blah blah
um
if you need some parts just call me
and uh i took his business over
how long did you go to jail for it
i don't know they didn't give you much
time for gta's back then probably two
three years but yeah so you had it
locked down for years then so you know
before back then when two years seemed
like a lot of time yeah you know it
ain't like you know when we started
selling cocaine it's like oh you're
looking at 40 from from zero to 40 and
we're probably going to get you
oh [ __ ] it's a whole different game so
it was definitely a different game but
um
i basically just took over his operation
man uh
i was 18 and had my own body shop
just from doing this yeah if i'm
stealing cars there's so many body shops
you would never be like well we're gonna
get busted like no [ __ ] not bro you
don't mind i was just
i was just stripping them in here yeah
yeah fixing no cars
cut them in little pieces
you know the night uh
that the police raided me your shop yeah
i had seven cars in there cut up i had
people cars cut in half cops cut off
cars moon roofs cut out of cars because
you know back then a moon roof was 300
bucks damn man that one car could be so
much money
yeah just by parting it out bumpers
fenders front-end doors a whole [ __ ]
empire another business right i never
thought about how much you could
probably make off each piece oh man
goodness cause i'm about to buy some
stuff like how much you want for the
rims [ __ ] man
they're not cheap i didn't know bro
they're they're expensive
yes so you got it going you got your
your car thing going then you see you
got arrested yeah you're getting raided
yeah i got arrested
so now um
teenager
i go to jail but my bill bill was cheap
only a thousand bucks my mom wow
my mom got me out right 100 bucks i said
mom i got 100 bucks on my dresser just
just put your house up
oh because you still have to put some
collateral yeah she put the collateral
up so she got me out and uh
i'm just now i'm like i'm [ __ ] up
again you know like
i've been making two three hundred
dollars a night now i ain't making [ __ ]
how long were you doing the car thing
before you got in trouble
i don't know probably about a year maybe
oh so you made some money i made a
little money but i put it all in that
[ __ ] chevy
what kind of card you had i had a 66
convertible no
running back
imagining it red for some reason but i
never painted it i never got no no i
never got around to painting it long as
you're driving it though with that
feeling of your own first car is so
different i just did the interior you
know at the interior redone and and i
was chroming all everything on the
bottom was gonna be chrome like the show
cars you're looking at yeah i went to
mine to look like a show car you know i
always want to be like [ __ ] that out
i'll wait i want to be the best yeah you
know so uh
i'm sitting on my mom's porch one day
broke
my car's sitting out there no gas
so i can't go ride pumps broke you know
i can't put pumps on it yeah cause i
can't steal cars no more you know like
how am i gonna get more money yeah you
know if i i don't want to get caught
again i got seven gta's right now seven
counts play county for all every car
every coin i got charged for damn
that's how they got them basically on
the
one your life sentence right like that
was the whole crux of you getting
yourself out it was it was a similar
similar situation you can't you can't
take all these different things like the
the whole point was don't like the three
strikes a lot you can't
you're supposed to go in learn from your
mistakes come out [ __ ] up get arrested
again go in learn your mistakes they're
just piling
we're hitting you with all these from
some [ __ ] we've been watching guys here
you've been studying alone you've been
to law school
i've been to the [ __ ] joe rogan
experience man
he knows he listens a lot of people
don't listen to you know people still
yeah
man
you get out of jail you had a life
sentence [ __ ] i studied yeah i
mean i learned the only thing you could
do in there do some push-ups and study
was that a new law
no it was all three strikes in the 90s
how the [ __ ] did that even go through
like it seems so obvious oh they've they
just wanted my stepdad
you know sometimes prosecutors be over
jealous
and then you'll get judges who are
really not judges
you know they just like prosecute the
puppets
uh what do you want me to get him okay
gotcha yeah dude
oh no
no what you say when you say the door
was at and they knocked at what time and
and you'll be like johnny they did knock
on the door and they just kicked the
door in they didn't have a search
warrant and no i didn't give them
permission to search my house you know
i'm telling you i didn't give them
permission well the police said you gave
him permission
uh john i would have gained permission i
had a thousand kilos
so you think i would have said it's okay
to search my trunk
and this was before they had the cameras
too right oh before that was a wild wild
west yeah yeah you are going to jail and
that's how it was that's how the freeway
task force came along you know the guys
who started stealing the money planting
the drugs
you know like we always get our guy
no matter who he is if he don't work for
us we gonna get him damn if he doesn't
work for uh oh [ __ ] so corrupt man yeah
yeah i was driving down the street one
night um
what's so crazy is i couldn't get
cocaine this week
this is one week this was one week i
could not get cocaine
you know it was like [ __ ] that i'm not
gonna pay no
ten thousand extra kilo for no cocaine
i'll just take off this week yeah and so
i'm just going around shooting
basketball and you know hanging with the
homies and
um
so i hadn't saw my homeboys in a couple
of months and i was like man let's go
and see the homies because i knew the
cops were after me you know then told
everybody they're like oh we're gonna
get that [ __ ] you know [ __ ] him
you guys think he's hot [ __ ]
so uh i go by and homies just gambling
they shooting dice and you know we sit
there and we talking [ __ ] they smoking
weed and drinking and i was like man i'm
gonna get out of here it's getting late
let me get out of here so
man until the homies jumped in the car
we put off we look up a [ __ ] car in
front of us with no lights on
i said man it's a [ __ ] car following
some no lights on so the homie pick his
pistol up he got that big 401 magnum
he's like man i'm a blast a
[ __ ] ass if it's some jackers
yeah so they put on the side of us they
let they tenant one they had ten and
windows i had ten in windows so they let
the tenant window down and we see the
green shift
he said oh man that's that [ __ ]
tomorrow
i said oh [ __ ]
tomorrow was the name of the cop
damn you guys know his [ __ ] name oh
he's on you then oh he didn't bust all
my homies seen him planted drugs on him
and everything beat the ass we all had
these scars in our face let me see where
that's going can you are you [ __ ]
kidding me that's from a cop smacking
you with a flashlight
yeah they splashed you with that all of
us had a cut we all got cuts
damn that's some cops going around while
i've arrested him before they hit you
hit you with that flashlight you hit you
with the edge of that flat knife
it switches you like it's got that it's
got that grain on the end yeah split you
like a knife so we all had that cut over
here
and uh my boy he had already just got my
boy
put a plastic bag over his head you know
i mean [ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah when you're
trying to make him open to safe and my
boy he's so hard with no money in the
safe no way we're just empty man i just
emptied the safe
couldn't have been more than an hour two
hours before they hit
i just take like seven hundred thousand
safe
and they hit right
about right there
but my boy like [ __ ] him
you know let him work for it and so he
don't tell him what the combination to
the safety like man i don't know the
combination so they put a plastic bag
over his head make him open the safe
torture in this floor yeah gang unit
[ __ ] dude yeah waterboarding them and
[ __ ] yeah yeah they got the legal gang
rights those [ __ ] should have been
man they should have put those i believe
crooked cops are the worst [ __ ] on
the whole planet because they make the
whole game unsafe
because now
you don't know if you should blast a cop
yeah you might just walk up how you
doing
and pop you yeah right because you don't
know yeah you know [ __ ] skin opposing
gang basically it is opposing even if
you're not in it gang they're still on
you they have the free range so so if
you're dealing with that it makes the
whole game just
like
[ __ ] who can i trust you know what i'm
saying if you're not gonna just arrest
me and take me to jail like you're
supposed to
take the evidence that you have
you know because you know the the rapper
he calls me a snitch because i i went i
testified against those cops
that's the only time you're supposed to
testify i hired him i hired a private
investigator
for the record i hired a private
investigator to go and follow those
[ __ ] around and build up evidence on
them wow and then when they arrested me
and they arrested me
i gave them the whole file like this
this is what your key witnesses
this is what your key witnesses
call all those people we got all the
names and numbers everybody that they
tortured and we had people who they
stuck
telephone cards too that was not like
you have a lamp and the card is broken
electrocute them election
these cops are out here doing this
[ __ ] that's crazy man i believe it
listen one of them was named
deliblo
like diablo like the album that's what i
thought he said
the devil sobel
that was sobel
he was the head i mean i've been wanting
to talk to these guys so bad i wish that
that that
that
we could sit down and talk like this
here you know where they open up and and
be truthful because a couple of them
went to jail but
they they're not gonna never talk what
they really did never come all the way
clean because they were so [ __ ] bad
man
people would hang their [ __ ]
ass if they did those guys were dirty
man they planted drugs on my mama they
what the [ __ ] on your mom my mom had a
daycare
they took a semi-sub machine gun
and put it up under her bed to take her
daycare license
to get at me
that's the kind of way they was doing
they
stopped my mom's preacher in the airport
they were going to a funeral
and checked all their luggage told me
they were carrying drugs from me they
hated you man
oh they hate you big time well you know
what happened though see i made a fool
out of them
you know i made them look bad
because they were going to the city and
the city was like hold up
they keep talking about this young
[ __ ] in l.a got all this money
selling all this dope
and y'all can't catch him
so they say oh we gonna catch him
oh it made him feel inadequate and [ __ ]
so now they're coming for your mom and
their homies did they respect that
evidence you gave them about their about
the cops oh yeah well they did yeah they
used it good [ __ ] they prosecuted the
cops went to trial that's that's that's
how i testified they went to trial
while you were on trial or after doing
the same time when they arrested me
they got arrested at the same time
it's like how is that not enough though
like if you get pulled over for a
speeding ticket and the cop doesn't show
up that [ __ ] is thrown out
it is but with the feds it's a little
yeah they want their 99 percent
conviction rate right they put a lot of
time and money and i had the option
though you know i probably could have
won
but it was like
if you testify against him
when i go to prison when i first go when
i first get downtown mdc i get down
there and all the homies is there who've
been there for years fighting their
cases and stuff and they're like man i'm
looking at life i'm looking at 30 i'm
looking at 40. i was like [ __ ] i want
10.
[Laughter]
so i tell my lawyer you're like look we
only have to fight
let me know how much money i got to pay
get me 10.
and then they was like
no [ __ ] you're not getting 10.
i'm like oh please give me 10.
i'll give you more money just give me 10
years so then one day right i'm in ohio
they shipped me to ohio
so this is when you got arrested yeah
i'm sitting in a cell in ohio and then
uh they come they come one morning early
like four in the morning and that's what
time they take you to courtney him get
dressed you're going to court
and i was like i ain't going to court
today
there ain't no court date for me he's
like
get dressed you're going to court and
i'll take back down in my bunk and then
about 30 minutes later come back we told
you to get dressed you're going to court
today
i was like man i ain't going to court my
court next next month
you going to court today the marshal's
coming to get you in a few minutes
so i get up get dressed like [ __ ]
gonna be a dry [ __ ] run i'm gonna sit
in that holding tank all day and
i said well at least i get to eat some
street food you know they're gonna get
me some
uh
i don't know burger king or something
alright some [ __ ] you know that like
they always buy us lunch when we go out
because
uh in cincinnati they didn't have a
cafeteria inside the jail for the
inmates
they would just go buy some little food
that was the highlight of being out
there right so
so i get the court and i look up
because they walk us straight through
the front door tonight like with that i
see my lawyer you're like man what the
hell you doing here he's like man i got
a call and they told me to get down here
i'm like yeah
i don't know we'll see let's go to court
so we go in there and then he come in
the room he was like man
they gonna indict those cops
i was like yeah
burger king and these folks are going to
jail we all going to be in jail together
you must have freaked out [ __ ] he was
like yeah it looked like they're going
to die them they they're going to make
your offer
i said yeah i said what they offered me
he said what you wanted 10.
i said yeah
and i said back i was like
[ __ ] that i ain't taking no 10 now
oh [ __ ] i said it i said
something is wrong if they offer me 10
now you know uh
i was begging for 10.
you know three four months ago and now
they wanna give me ten
and we know they gonna indict them cops
i said my case looked pretty good
so uh we was able to get it down to i
played guilty to the 10.
if i testified it was gonna knock off
another five so oh wow yeah so i was
like
i'll go for that oh yeah i won't take no
chance going to trial but knowing that
i'll be out and then i'd already been in
jail like
19 months two years or something you
know so i was like [ __ ] i'm close to the
house man i could see the door and then
i knew all my homies who was
in 30s and 40s and knives and
and um
i just feel fortunate you know to take
that to have that opportunity
but that all came from me too being
proactive you know like hiring an
investigator you know an investigator
cost me a hundred thousand dollars oh
damn how long was he working for
investigator yeah i don't know probably
about
90 days 100 days he didn't work that
long you know but you know he had to
work long hours man those guys
those guys were busy you know those guys
was they was like dope dealers man like
all night let's raise somebody else we
pray to somebody let's get somebody else
we can get money like this here you know
they had houses on on the river and and
all kinds of they was living like you
know they was looking like dope aways
yeah matter of fact one of them we did
get one of them to talk a little bit
in my documentary i don't know if did
you see the documentary no i haven't
seen it oh you got to see which one's it
called freeway cracking the system no no
i haven't seen i don't even know where
you can find it at now you know they
stole that from me too
didn't get paid for that no mark levin
shady ass he stole it from me
how are people benefiting off your story
i don't understand that's what i never
understand it's [ __ ] ridiculous
well
okay look at this here
you go to court
and the first thing they say
ex-drug dealer
convict the felon
so you know what you do when they say
that you lose your credibility
uh god you got you when you're trying to
sue that but it's still breaking the law
though 100
it it it doesn't matter when you're a
second-class citizen
if you're a second-class citizen you you
lose your rights and even though you're
supposed to get him back you know once
you get out of prison it's like a
tainted thing like well he used to do
this so what is he doing now no money
it's not gonna go with the court we're
against the rapper like how the [ __ ]
you you know he so obvious [ __ ] stole
my name you know like he didn't think
you were ever getting out so he's like
you know what what's he gonna do i'm
gonna take his [ __ ] persona and
identity which doesn't make sense to me
how can you do that legally that is a
thing in hip-hop but they're paying
homage this fool was like acting like he
didn't know who freeway rick was
yeah and he didn't pay you nothing
nothing no
you figured and then the judge and then
the [ __ ] judge find a way
to let him off
no no royalties no nothing nothing then
tell him he can still use the name
i didn't know that part just huffle bags
of money
if that ain't if that ain't if what he
did is not identity theft except there
directly is it's identity theft i mean
it's no more than taking your name
going to the bank
going into your bank account
except it's just not cash money out of a
bank but it's other
equity you know like i i
i i was thinking to myself a couple of
days ago you know i was thinking and i
was like wow
i know why you're so fortunate
and as i talk to myself
you know i like to talk to myself and
that's how i analyze my situations and
calculate and stuff like that and i was
like wow
you put a lot of [ __ ] equity out here
you know you've helped a lot of people
you've done a lot of favors you treat a
lot of people right
and that's why things come back to you
you know
and what he did is he capitalized
on that
that i had created brand
you know
um
but the judge the judge didn't see it
that way you know they they didn't feel
that um
that i had value i guess i don't know
what i don't know how the world didn't
react more to that and let this full
continue what i don't understand is how
is he going to keep making songs and go
to sleep at night knowing that he didn't
give you no money for his [ __ ]
existence the same dude that was a
corrections officer though that's what
i'm saying like
it is blatant hollywood [ __ ] yeah can
you imagine
the number one gangster
rapper in the whole world
used to pat [ __ ] down and tell
them to spread their cheeks
and lift their feet up and check it oh i
heard about them you know what i'm gonna
rap let me get his name he's not getting
out right all right let me get his [ __ ]
that's exactly what happened yeah i feel
i feel like i can't ever listen to any
song of that man again i always wanted
to ask you this because like nipsey was
my favorite rapper all the time i grew
up on hollywrap did you get do you get
offended when la rappers like
collaborate with him and [ __ ]
i just you know i just shake my head you
know yeah it's not like get your [ __ ]
money bro go ahead yeah yeah it's one of
those like same way i did with michael k
you know yeah like when he told me he
was going to play my role you know i i
didn't think it was cool
you know
to to participate
because i i felt that
even the directors
to put me in it knowing that i'm alive
and
not saying you know what we know this
[ __ ] just got out of prison he's on
his ass
give him something for his name we're
going to put his name on him
give him a role in a [ __ ] budget
ah some people don't reciprocate man but
it's okay because in the end just like
you said just i shake my head a little
bit yeah i'll win so i question you know
i question i question all that you know
like when when you see people
collaborate with them and
and snoozing up but you know i mean
he had he had the most powerful record
labels in the business behind him so
people kissed up to to to to that
and so many people were not
you know they're not like
us
or like drug dealers you know
drug dealers create their own
uh uh
revenue streams you know we don't look
for people to come in and and
to rescue us you know never to take care
of us so
when when you're looking at at
people like that you look at it in a
different light
than than
if they like
you know like the basic
drug dealers you know and and and
i don't know i i love the drug dealer
mentality
it's the best mentality yeah it's making
something out of nothing exactly and
it's also
pull other people up with you yeah doing
it alone never works yeah you know
they're always recruiting and you know
like you look at a lot of the guys who
make their money through rapping
they take the money and they just
harvest it
or if they make any money yeah we don't
even know if they really make money true
it must be some record label facade [ __ ]
yeah a lot of times you know the label
bomb a rental car
and some jewelry found out about that a
couple years ago when i moved here i go
wait you rented that [ __ ] well yeah i
rented it to him but
my whole world is broken now bro i
didn't know it was all fake yeah yeah
it's a massage a facade so uh when you
look at all that and you'll be like ah
man i don't know what the [ __ ] to
believe you know still your own thing at
that point yeah yeah that's all anything
else works like how can i make something
out of nothing again
exactly yeah do you think that's what
made you so much more successful than
other people selling drugs was you had
that like team you knew you had to build
out a team to like be able to scale you
had a did you have like a more of a
business mind like what was it yeah you
know i i what i looked at is i was like
okay rick you could sell an ounce of
cocaine
but what if you had 40 guys that could
sell an ounce of coke for you you know
and off of those guys you don't even
need to get as much as you get off your
ounce
you know because you ain't doing any
work
if you could just get
100 bucks off their ounce
and then you got 30 of them some
contracts that's 100 bucks off of each
person's ounce and then you still got
all the money off of your own ounce too
you just killed the game yeah you just
became mcdonald's so that's the way i
looked at it and that's the way i expand
it
and that's still the way i expand right
now today you know with with everything
that i do i try to
uh show other people
how to be like me
that's this guy delegate yeah delegate
things so you could
we're scaling keep scaling because
there's only 24 hours in the day so
there's no way to gain more time
building your team out enough to really
support it especially what we're talking
about what you were doing and [ __ ] is
like i can't imagine it's hard i run a
goddamn graphic design business it's
hard to [ __ ] build up a good that's
different that's different yeah so uh
going back to saying you said your homie
gave you a rock 50 rock and you said go
make money so after you get out of jail
you said you're down bad no more money
from the cars you can't sell steal cars
no more your homie gives you a rock and
you say what is this
right
and then what happened you just went and
sold it and just i just started going
around asking everybody what was it
because i didn't believe him
or you know if it was a real drug no i
never saw cocaine before
only thing only time i saw cocaine was
in the movies
oh [ __ ] this is pr
this is pre scarface then yeah it was
before scarface is 81. it was before
right before school face
so was it super popular it was still
kind of like a new thing that might like
that was new it was new
to the average people but like the
entertainers were already you know the
richard myers the rick james the sly and
the family stones damn you just threw it
back damn the family yeah yeah you know
the guys who had money yeah
you know the people i mean the average
person couldn't afford it
the first gram of cocaine i got was cost
like 350 bucks
the gram a gram and it had cut on it
i mean like it's like 90 right now for
the craziest coke in the world right now
i don't know i could take that gram i
could take that gram
break it down and make 900 bucks
oh so you're just cutting it
three ways
you know what's funny is when someone
buys a gram they never go this is cut
they go no i only bought a gram and
stored it all at once so anybody who
bought a gram you you could you could
scam them essentially
i did when i was like i was getting
scammed for all the little sacks i was
getting so i started buying eight balls
and buying little half zips and for you
know
friends throw in and we all just get
[ __ ] up all night but
i i never
i never got into that that's just a
whole life you have to be prepared 24
hours a day have somebody with you you
better have a gun
because mercedes all meth
so it's it's a little meth dealer's a
little different man oh no doubt they're
a little a little grimy all right it
gets in the locker
a lot grimy it gets hectic over the mf
is
it's the devil
it's truly the devil and coke is a party
and meth is the devil
that's how i always saw it yeah that mef
is tough yes yes so
you went around because you didn't
believe it was a real drug yeah and i
just started asking everybody hey man is
this really cocaine and
finally i ran into one of my big homies
who was a pimp and uh
he said come on let me go see
of course he smoked the whole thing up
wait he smoked was it a cracker
he turned it into a crack rock oh that's
why he said he handed you a raw i
thought you just meant like a little
rock okay no it was a powder rock
that's what i'm assuming okay but he
smoked just straight powder no he cooked
it oh so he did okay yeah i saw him cook
it i saw it that's the first time i ever
saw anybody cook
wow i explain all that in my book though
you know when you get a chance you gotta
read yeah what kind of it's on audible
too right
yeah but that audible ain't mine so
don't worry all right
somebody else somebody else ripping me
off but i don't know
it gives my audience a chance to hear
the book the ones who won't buy it they
get to listen to it
uh
and you know the book is doing good
anyway so i'm just gonna be happy yeah
be happy yeah don't hate be happy yeah
the best it's the best way to live man
so so was it like was it crack you were
dealing with also or was it coke like
first it was coke
crack came later on i mean they were
cooking in the crack
but that's not how you were selling it
but i didn't know how to because i
didn't know how to cook it the other
part of the story was if i'm not
mistaken is that there was like they
would give you there's unjust laws
surrounding how much more time you would
get for the crack that came later though
that didn't come to 87. we talked about
79. oh wow
so you're what 19 20 years old you start
selling it and now you're actually
seeing real money
yeah well you know it started off
20 bucks a week a week yeah
oh cause 350 a great it was the most
expensive thing in the world because
nobody can afford it everybody could
afford the only people could afford it
was the pimps
no
what a weird different world man yeah
the pimps was the only one that could
afford it and then
i found out about the pcp guys
the guys who sold the pcp angel does and
pcp they could afford it too
because you know they might make three
four hundred dollars a day so you know
they'd spend 50 bucks on some cocaine
you know like freebase and they all put
it together by eighth or
you know a gram or something and i was
like oh yes i hit the jackpot yeah and
then i found a street that had like
20 or 30 pcp guys on it oh [ __ ] and you
know they all did the same thing you
know once one started smoking he turned
another one on and they want to see who
could smoke the biggest rock and who
could spend the most money and you know
the same little games but for me it
turned into a gold mine yeah i'm turning
to where now making 500 a day
you know damn a day and i'm still eating
50 cent uh burritos for sure from taco
pizza stack that [ __ ]
uh no matter how much until recently i'm
like i'll spend more than two bucks on
myself
yeah i know i know that feeling
so
um
it just kept growing from there you know
and i kept pulling the money all back
you know
taking just enough out to eat
and and i mean it changed though
eventually moved up to
buying weight
it changed because i kept pulling the
money back
you know i kept taking 500 and i make
500 a day then the next day i go spend a
thousand and the next day i spend 1500
and the next day
the 1500 might turn into
2300 or 2500 and i just kept scaling it
up scouting it up
i learned that the more you buy the
cheaper it got
at first i didn't know that because i
would just buy just to have more ounces
around
and then um eventually i found out that
the more you buy that's for a dollar
discount
so you know i was paying 2 800 and i was
like man i'm buying four can i get it
for 27.
it's 400 bucks back though that's the
whole day work for back then yes 400
savings yes not counting your profit
that you already normally make so now
every day i start making an extra 400.
so that turned into
you know
and it just kept going you know and then
i i started recruiting people you know
to people you knew around your
neighborhood yes that like money yeah
so everybody's looking to you like no
ricky's a tennis player and the next
year like
how the [ __ ] you driving that car
basically right yes
wow what a change that's like a movie
scene man yes yes yes one day i'm
driving a car with a crate you know the
milk crate like the crate they doing the
crate contest yeah yeah i was sitting on
that mother in the car
driving down the street with a crate
[Laughter]
yo what an iconic scene
uh
a year old cutlass
nice joystick what were you doing you're
a kid with money at that point what are
you spending money on besides oh just
re-up they're just re-upping you know i
buy cars i would go to the auction and
buy a car you know and flip a car and
because i still you know i still like
cars you know i still have my fetish for
cars
you know so i'll go to the auction buy a
cutlass you know need a fender or
something
you know pay the boys hey go get me that
fender
give me the hood
give me the bumper
you know so i was doing the same thing
that i should do now i'm buying from
other people yeah because i knew the
game so like y'all i hope this will make
some money because i used to be in that
position right there yes yes nice so
when did it just start getting to the
point where
now the i remember the officer you
called him but he knows you by heart he
knows you by name and now he hates your
ass well what happened is is
i was putting out so much equity
you know throwing equity everywhere
you're throwing bricks to people and
they're moving though they moved them
oh you were mixing in square joe here
did it matter it didn't matter no all
money's money never mind i needed a crew
yeah because i find a a i found a source
you know unlimited source
so i'm limited source
yeah i mean i need people to move that
says on your wikipedia page
thousands of employees
damn i wanted millions
and you know cocaine has a way of moving
around you know that [ __ ] might start in
colombia and then winds up in iowa
you know and i got to [ __ ] get to
iowa to you know somebody made money the
whole way exactly somebody's paying the
rent for each time it stopped which is i
know it's drugs i understand but damn
that was helping people pay their rent
and eat and everything absolutely
yeah i mean
where i'm from
people with a nice car you probably sell
meth
you know but
at the same time when you go to the
family you're like oh he's doing so good
blah blah and it's like it's not frowned
upon when you can take care of your
family yes yes
right when aunty uh getting kicked out
of her house and you go to the landlord
and say oh here all the money is don't
kick her out
it matters
extra
months rent you know
and it's a good feeling of course you
know and i enjoyed it
and
i'm sure other people who are in the
game enjoy
being in the game for those same type of
reasons yes
okay
so i got a question i i thought your
nickname was freeway rick ross it could
i mean this might be wrong here on
wikipedia just because you grew up by
the freeway but it says because you
bought up so many properties along the
freeway
was it hard to buy properties and [ __ ]
like actual things not really it was
easy to buy properties back then
and you know i studied the property game
i i i got really good at in real estate
really started buying up houses yeah i
was building houses that would be the
point to me that's where you want your
money if you're gonna like
well i i that's what everybody told me
but uh what i found out is that
that's partially
as long as you don't have a collapse in
the market you know we had that collapse
in the market and when i went to prison
the market collapsed
right right during the time that i went
to prison so it kind of like
and not turn out to be as good as it it
it was you know at one time
huh
that's crazy though you're doing all
this in south central all this this
whole time yeah i didn't have enough
sense to go nowhere else wow
so i i just find it crazy that you're
now it's the 80s right
and gangs are starting to get more
prevalent like around l.a area like
you're saying you're a kid and you saw
the crypts around your
school so by the time you're 10 15 years
older
that's on every corner now essentially
right yeah
okay so i just find it i've never heard
that like being able to sell
to multiple people but then again
if they're all making money why
mess up the money well when
one of one of my friends told me
something like this here he said that i
created the first peace treaty
three because
when we were at our height
crips and bloods would be on the same
block selling dope
wow
and
you know money money are by
peace
for sure
they tried in the middle east you know
they ain't giving the right money to the
right people though sometimes yeah but
but yeah you know when when when people
have an opportunity to make some money
they'll they'll put their grievances to
the side
and and try to make peace i i think the
gangs really got worse when they locked
up all the drug boys all the main
because then you know they did like a
sweeping l.a like they just swept la and
and locked up all of the major players
so now nobody's got no money
yeah cause all the major players are in
prison they're all in mdcla you know
when i got there that's that's when i
told you when i got there all my friends
was there oh man i'm looking at 30. i'm
looking at life
oh they trying to give me 40 years and
damn
70 years you know how crazy though you
you cut off
the money and now the crime gets worse
because what do you have to do i'm gonna
go rob somebody i have to pay my [ __ ]
rent yeah i'm gonna hit somebody in here
it has to then what else you're gonna do
i'm gonna hit him in here because i want
some dope
oh another strung out too i should i
could have got some good cheap dope when
they was around i could get some good
teeth cheap dope keep myself high i was
a functioning drug addict you know go to
work every day you know
i'm gonna take 15 20 out of my check
and get me some some dope
i'm good but you know when that's no
longer around now you have to deal with
people who really didn't care who was in
this
scrupulous you know guys are selling
fake dope and you know just all kind of
stunts that took place
damn dude so
how many years were you on your run like
i i read up on it but like you said
about six or seven years before those
cops really were just well the cops got
on me and and i think that was like
87 is when 86 is like when i when i
first heard about them right because
they raided a couple couple people
houses
you know but they didn't find nothing
you know planted small amounts of dope
because they didn't really know how big
we was matter of fact you know uh the
cop who who's in the documentary
he said that when people were telling
that we had millions in south central
they didn't believe it
they thought people were lying so
you got a thousand kilos in a house
it's just a regular house in the
neighborhood and there just happens to
be that much lack of money in there yeah
well why why not who would know
wow who would know let somebody tell
them that's true
hey what's up guys welcome to our
mid-roll ad read this is one of our
sponsors on it as you know ana is a
fitness health nutrition brand human
optimization is their slogan basically
what i'm saying any nutrient any vitamin
anything you can possibly think of to
make your body work better your brain
work better on it offers it as always
guys you can go to
www.aunit.com that's o-n-n-i-t dot com
forward slash yola and that's 10 off of
everything in the store except for
weights so alpha brain is the flagship
product for on it this is what they
started with it's something that i take
every single day they just dropped alpha
brain black label every single thing
that on it offers is started and
sprouted from the alpha brain product so
yes you see on it has the weights has
the gear has the whey protein all that
crazy [ __ ] for your body this is
obviously alpha brain this is for your
brain this is vitamins for your thinking
vitamins for your focus one of the
things i really love about on it they
have a subscription-based platform you
can go buy individually a la cart
whatever you want to do but if you want
alpha brain at your door every day you
can set it to where they will send it
the same time every single month or
weeks or days however you want to do it
just because like i said i do 75 things
a day sometimes i'll forget to reorder
something and you know what it's like
you forget and it's a week later it's a
week later it's a month later then you
go oh yeah i used to take alpha brain so
if you're a person like me try the
subscription based plan it's just easier
it comes to your house every month it's
it can't get easier so as i said go to
onit.com that's
onnit.com forward slash yola that's our
code that's our personal code for the
dope as usual podcast that gets you 10
off of all supplements and all the gear
thank you guys so much for supporting
the brands that support us back to the
episode
yeah you got to read the la magazine
article
of
about me the the whole wait la magazine
article
article magazine yeah
they're going from trying to kick you
put you in jail but now it's a good
story so they're taking advantage of
that well they they first wrote they
wrote my obituary
why because they said i was dead i was
never getting out of prison i had a life
sentence without so they wrote your
obituary because you're in jail yeah
jesse cats did that's [ __ ] up said i
was gonna die in prison
and it feels like that too you know
you've got these big ol ass concrete
walls you know like three feet thick you
know and
[ __ ] metal everywhere rusty ass metal
and
people getting stabbed and hitting here
with bats and
it's it's a jungle yeah
used to uh
used to uh ride around with the cops
that's the reporter he's a reporter for
that eight times oh so he was pissed and
wrote your obituary because he got
caught well he wasn't pissed no he
didn't get caught he was he he was clean
no because you because you're in jail
now he's like yeah i'm gonna write it
because he's riding around with the cops
they all got a vendor they've been
writing the whole stories you know he he
been keeping track he's he's documenting
the the history of l.a
you know he says that's a reporter's job
it's the document what's going on in the
city
and so that's what he had been doing you
know the cops are chasing blah blah blah
blah blah
and uh he covered the story when the
cops went to trial and he did all that
wow so now
i'm in prison with a life center without
the possibility of parole so it was only
right for him to cover it
i know it's what a little [ __ ] jab
like here's your obituary read it oh so
when he comes down to do the story
um
i start to tell him all the things that
i'm gonna do when i get out of prison
he thinks i've lost my mind
he thinks i went crazy that's why the
story is amazing they did they did about
about 13 pages
he's a good writer too i mean this
story is amazing you got to read that
story
la magazine you said l.a magazine i will
read that 2013 and it's called rick
ross's dreaming
it's dreaming wow
you really didn't think you're getting
out he didn't think i was getting out so
you should have seen the first day that
we hooked up when i got out right and
i'm going i'm going to hollywood to
speak at an aaa
meeting
really
what a flip of the script man going
being in prison now you're sorry
up to hollywood
and uh i speak i do my little speak and
then we talk when when you know and i
was like man you catching a train i'm
going right by downtown l.a where l.a
times is
i'll get you a ride you ain't gotta
you ain't [ __ ] gotta catch the train
man i mean you could
there it is right there he pulled it up
already
uh
yeah we got to read this that's crazy so
um
when uh
we driving down the freeway and i see
this guy [ __ ] guys just like
you know like dumbfounded
you know and i looked at my like what
the [ __ ] wrong with you man
you finna have a seizure son
[ __ ]
he's like man you driving down the 110
freeway
oh
[ __ ]
i'm in a beat up kia with the cracked
wood shield he's put all that [ __ ] in
it's all in the article he he described
the card to the t you know i have to
write a thousand dollars for the card
you know and we just got out but i
didn't care
i was free
with all the game i had
now i ain't even got to exercise my game
yet you know i'm still like
because i really need some more bread
before i really like really really
exercise this [ __ ] i i know some [ __ ]
i mean ford's making money uh
i don't know man this [ __ ] is gonna be
crazy
he he said it's already crazy in this
article he said oh no the story is
already crazy
nine years ago i said no
it's gonna be crazy now i've been out 12
years going on 13 years now oh i thought
it was 2010.
no i got it
that is oh yeah 12 years in yeah i got
it oh damn how long were you in there
i did 20. two bits
20. that's my baby girl there
they think she's gonna be a tennis pro
at 14. no [ __ ]
yeah no that's cool man
that is like that's a cool feeling right
there son my son is in there too he's in
the article they got to pick where he
said oh that's when i was at i went here
he went with me to a halfway house and
those are all guys that's in prison and
i'm talking to guys in prison
that's me talking to guys in prison wow
have you encountered anybody that had
the same three strikes issue that you
did
uh
i knew guys that had it when i was in
prison not not only did they get out or
was yours like a precedence
uh no it was already presidents who was
already set because it was just the law
they just basically
see see what what what what threw
everybody off in my case
is that
my cases was from different states
oh
so they thought that if you caught
two cases in la
at the same time
they stack up as felonies because that
three-strike [ __ ] is a california thing
that's a california thing it's a federal
thing too is it i thought it was just
california
but what them though this is what thorne
is that there was different states
so they saying if it's different states
they got to be different convictions
it's [ __ ] stupid
which is which is i mean if if you think
about it you would say ah you know you
went to two separate courts
you know separate courthouses
separate judges separate prosecutors
different cases and cases
but that's not what the forefathers
wanted to be
the forefathers was thinking
you know they they had already thought
about you know it might be a guy who
uh
sells dope
to 100 people in one day
i mean you could literally sell
dope to 100 people in one day yeah and
going by what these guys thought you
would be a [ __ ] or criminal i mean
immediately one day
one day you were saying then you know
your son needed surgery and you said man
i'm gonna go make 30 000 and you make
100 sales
then those are literally separate
arrests i mean separate
sales
so what through them is that
these different states
well yours is different states and don't
say anything about states and i'm like
well the states doesn't really
it's not the key points the key points
is the intervening arrests
the intervening arrests
is the keys
and what that mean by that is that
had the person learn their lesson
had they ever been told that what you're
doing is wrong
and if you've never been told that what
you're doing is wrong how could you know
that what you're doing was wrong
and
they just couldn't get past the part
that it was separate states
and
i i tried to explain to him that the
important parts was was you ever out of
handcuffs
if he was in handcuffs the whole time
then you only went to court one time
even if you went to courts all over the
country
it's still considered only only one time
and and that just thrown you know they
just couldn't get by now mine was
presidents on a person with multiple
state cases
you know different cases in different
was it like a moment of clarity when you
read a line in the law book and you
realized or was it not like that you're
well yeah because you know with me see
what i had did
i had become
in tune
i i stopped watching tv i stopped
listening to the radio i didn't play any
card games
uh no more table games no more chess
mine was just strictly
trying to understand what the foreign
fathers who wrote the law was trying to
say did you suspect that there was
something in there or you were just like
that's all you had searching you know
you you you you know
there's a saying in jail
they always make a mistake
you know they always make a mistake so
it's your job to find that mistake
and and uh that's what i was searching
for i was just
urging for a mistake and then it just it
just popped out you know
and i had the clarity to to
to
to interpret
what they were saying how long were you
in jail before you realized i'm gonna
start hitting the books and see what the
[ __ ] were they [ __ ] up at
uh it only took a couple months oh damn
you were fighting it the whole time my
first six months i was kind of like
shell shocked because you had a life
sentence and
i had lied to my kids
when i got out i had kids that were
about
11
uh
when i got out the first time
it was about 10 11 you know from the
crooked cops
and i promised him that i was never
going back
and i promised him that i was never
gonna sell drugs again
so when
my whole arrest was entrapment
because i was not planning on selling
drugs
i had came up with a
small little game plan you know uh
getting into the record business
doing some boxing
uh i look back at my life and and and
and i had saw that
i was around all these athletes
that looked up to me
you know
uh um
you know the dural strawberries the
eric davises the elvin campbell
el wayne camel and
i mean some great dudes like i should
have a basketball league
and we'd have nba guys playing in the
league you know
um
and when i was in prison during those
five years i thought about and i was
like well man you could have been
helping those guys with their careers
you could have made those guys better
you know you know how to make people
better
so
uh
i just thought about it and i said
that's what you're gonna do when you get
out you know you're gonna start helping
guys like that and uh
it just
they didn't let it be you know they they
sick the sky on me
and i was putting together this theater
right on crenshawn adams i bought this
theater right before i got arrested
and this theater was gonna be like a a
hub where i was going to make it where
kids from the ghetto
could meet the guys like magic johnson
who are scared to come to los angeles
you know like they won't come to watts
and hang out with the kids yeah but the
kids need to meet those kind of guys you
know to understand that
these guys are just human
they're not because a lot of times you
know kids think like
a michael jordan is not
not normal
you know they don't understand that he
worked
to get to where he got to and i thought
that it would be important to make it
where these type of people could
actually mingle
with the have-nots you know where they
would feel safe and coming and so i was
going to build this theater i was going
to have computers a track music studio
like all the rappers was coming around
king t
dj pooh chocolate
ser jinx
uh
dre even passed by a few times you know
so uh
my goal was to build this theater and
make it where like a safe haven you know
where kids could come in and get some
computer training and just
tutoring
uh just all the things that that that i
know that i needed to to to
that would have made me successful yeah
and uh
they sick this guy on me
and he started dangling
cocaine in front of me
you want it
seventeen
thousand a kilogram oh
damn kilo is going for like 22
five off and i'm like ah
no
no are you broke at this point no you
just bought a theater i'm broke no i'm
broke oh so i brought the theater before
i went to prison so you're just being a
good citizen trying to get the [ __ ] done
for your community at this point so
fifteen thousand fifteen thousand
why are you going around so so so my my
my informant was also my old drug
supplier so he's like why are you going
around asking people to help you do your
theater you can do it yourself
i got everything you need
12 thousand a kilo so these guys were
just trying to bait you to sell again
and i'm like nah man i'm good i'm good
i'm good i'm good i'm gonna make it in
this rap business
uh
so one day one of my little homies
who used to be in a dope game with me
is ryan with me
he got bread he's been he's been looking
out for me you know buying me clothes
and
making sure i got gas money and
everything you know looking out
we ride and then dude call me
he pick up on the conversation he like
man
let me do that [ __ ] for you
should we go by dude restaurant he
bugged the whole time
so
knocked me off
that's how i get the life sentence
off that one meeting
no it was several meetings
in a short time conspiracy to distribute
six months it took six months i was out
six months
oh man give me the conspiracy to sell
cocaine
now was that was that the colombian dude
yeah no no he was nicaraguan nicaraguan
yeah yeah danilo blandon they
trapped this entrapment in it it was
entrapment all the way i thought it was
you know the law says that
you're not supposed to target
a person who's not selling drugs
it's illegal because
the way the way the way the forefathers
looked at the law is that you can almost
get anybody to commit a crime
for sure you know everybody has a price
and
it would almost be like you know like
you see a homeless person walking down
the street you know they down on their
luck ain't got no money and you be like
hey man see that car over there
some money in that car and the keys is
in it too
like the bait car [ __ ] show they had
that's entrapment but even worse than
that
debate car they just need a car there
they don't tell you to bother that's
true
but what they do
is they can have an informant
to go to you and tell you
that it's there and the keys is in and
there's money in it to go get it
because he's not an agent
oh a little bad little loophole i see it
a cop can't do that but he can tell this
guy but you want to get out of jail
earlier go tell him that you know you
can give it to her for 12.
so that's how my case went down so my
case was entrapment it was [ __ ] up
you know
so they got you and you never even sold
a thing again no never touched the drugs
then how did they give you a life
sentence from because they were bringing
the drugs
they were bringing the drugs
100 kilos
and they were striking me
damn they knew exactly what the [ __ ]
they were they had it all lined up
that's a perfect plan if i want to get
some guy that's not been game if we
can't get you plus you already know you
already know the philosophy behind
drug dealers you don't study drug
dealers you study them you know them
you want to be one kind of
probably so that's i think a big thing
about it so that's how that's how i went
back to prison you know and it hit you
with a life sentence when you're trying
to go straight
that guy hates you that's all he just
has a little vendetta well you know
i i had did uh i did a doc documentary
when i got out of prison you know i came
on first tonight right after monday
night football oh [ __ ] the first time
you got the first time i got out yeah oh
that must have made him heated now he's
on tv after [ __ ] football that's what
they're thinking monday night football
not just after football monday night
football
hey they got commercials i'm on
commercials during the middle of the
football game oprah winfrey oh no
foreign show i'm on commercial it came
on abc when when she was with abc damn
that's big
they saw that
yes probably it was huge and then the
guy jesse katz
he wrote an article
about me being out
um
he made a statement that the ellie times
had said that i had tapped into a
distribution network that the black
community had never really used
what would that distribution network be
using
street guys to sell the product
isn't that how most drugs get sold
though
it is but
they didn't use it the way i use it it
was what they were saying you know
you're using a fortune 500 company i
guess i don't i don't know i got to read
that article again you know i got to
read some of these articles that that
they're really cause some of these
articles really gave me my my seed
to what i do now
oh really yeah you know i started
reading articles and they would say oh
he sold drugs like walmart
what did walmart do
so they're breaking down letting you
know why you're successful and you're
like oh is that why i'm [ __ ] that's the
term for it
yeah we're just doing it i did it i went
and got the book on sam walton and read
them every book he wrote
really yeah
because i want to know what the sam
walton do like i did
what do what do we have in common
he should do the start of walmart right
yeah he is
yeah [ __ ] billionaire
he used to let each the person that ran
each department treated like their own
store right
that was like one of the things that i
remember that stood out he's like we we
got our team leaders and you treat your
section like it's your own store yeah he
he was just he was different
different dude yeah really humble
uh stayed low-key you know he was the
richest man in the world he drove his
same old pickup truck with his hound
dogs in the back
and uh this guy this guy um
one of the guys who interviewed in the
story he made a statement that uh
when sam came to pick him up from the
airport
he was looking to jump into the rolls
royce
and he said he had this old pickup truck
and the pickup truck the seat was worn
out on the passenger side and had a
spring that was sticking him in the ass
[Laughter]
yo i mean that's how rich people stay
rich man
they said low-key and that's all they
need is what their necessities man and
he got you know sam got lucky too he got
lucky a few times
but but you know that's what i did
another one said i sold drugs like
mcdonald's so i went and got the book on
mcdonald's that's the way i said early
bites so you did it like mcdonald's
they like they they cover the whole
property i make money off you and you're
selling it with my name making me more
popular thank you pay me
that's that's what you were doing so is
that what inspired you to write the
second book then
no the second book
the second book was like it's a stroke
of luck yeah uh this guy wrote me when i
was getting out i was about i had about
nine months left i guess
and this guy out of new york named cody
crutcher wrote me and he was like hey
man i got a magazine called get money
and i think it would be appropriate to
put you on the cover
and i said oh yeah
i'd only been on one of the cover of a
magazine before so i was like hell yeah
i'll do it
[ __ ] get money i like that what a great
title
uh when i got out you know we set up
with my p.o and he paid for me to come
to new york bought me a suit and put me
in a hotel for a week and the whole nine
yards and and we went around new york
and uh
what was we selling my t-shirts i think
no no no i wasn't selling the t-shirts
then that's it there get money magazine
that picture been all over the place
yeah that's like like headshot right
yeah
cody cody the guy who who co-authored
this book
he uh he that's his picture he too he
paid for that picture
so
when we finish in new york 21 keys of
success yeah what a [ __ ] title when
when we uh when we when we finished the
uh
we finished the interview all the photo
shoots and everything
um
he was like damn man i want you to go
i was like man [ __ ] i gotta get back to
l.a [ __ ] i don't care what you
doing i'm going back to l.a i'm not
going to go back to jail
and he's like man what if i come out in
l.a and hang out with you for about six
months
he said i'll pay all my own way i you
know i do everything myself
and i was like [ __ ] i ain't got nobody
to hang with i ain't by myself anyway
you can come hang with me
and uh
i had told him about my three favorite
books when i was in prison i was like
man no way you bought you chasing money
and you ain't read these books something
wrong with you
and uh
everybody that i read about danny had
read those three books sam walnut um he
read those three books
so uh
i was like ah come on out and hang out
so he comes out and he's hanging out and
uh
he's going with me to all my meetings
you know at this time
everybody's after me about my movie
rights you know i meet
four most powerful guys in hollywood i'm
sitting in their office and and they're
trying to make me offers on by my movie
rights and
i'm like okay
thank you but no thank you
too low yeah they they all tried to
lowball me chump me out you know they
thought because i was broke i was a
chump i was like man i was broke in
prison i wasn't no trump though
nobody [ __ ] me in prison you might say
a lot of stuff ain't nobody gonna tell
you they [ __ ] me
so uh
cody was with me
and one day we we
we uh we go down and we get in the car
and we're riding off
and i look over and he's in this little
yellow tablet and he's just john down
though
i said man every time i we we every time
we leaving meetings on you always
writing in that damn pad what you
writing
he's like oh i just been keeping a
journal
i said
wait a minute
you been keeping a journal from the day
that
you got there you got here
and you you you been keeping notes to
all the [ __ ] i've been going through and
doing i said man that's a book
wait so he involuntarily wrote a book
just by keeping his notes yeah we took
his notes and made a book that's amazing
yeah what a good [ __ ] idea
that was my idea that's a great idea to
keep the notes but it was my just like
yo turn that [ __ ] into a book
how cool that's how you browse your
second book that's how it got inside
what a [ __ ] story man that's awesome
and then he he figured out the keys that
i was using
for my success
you're and you're a ceo to a giant
company just didn't know it you're doing
the same tactics same business practices
that these legal guys in suits are doing
making that money too like [ __ ] billions
and [ __ ] like that you could put you
should put that on the shelf next to
those books you're reading right that's
like how i see it well i think my books
i think you know when it's all said and
done that my books will be
in that vein because
my books are
think and grow rich riches man babylon
as a man think they are those books
level from a guy who couldn't read
perspectives you know i mean even though
in in and think or rich you know you got
henry ford who couldn't read either
you know so so uh
crazy my story was just so similar to
all of these different people blue books
i read and
and i was like [ __ ] man yours just
happens to be illegal i should have i
should
that's it i mean it goes down in the
history books the same i mean yeah it
just happened to be you sold something
illegal
who made it illegal exactly if not why
why
why is that illegal and not alcohol when
more people died off alcohol and died
off cocaine you know cigarettes you know
cigarette killed more people than all
legal drugs put together so yeah
um
but i believe that my books will go down
for sure this one here this one here is
definitely going to be
a best-selling book you know
we'll link it in the description on
everything too for sure first so
everybody check this out find out about
it you know uh like even with joe i
ain't been back on joe since my book
been out you know if i went on joe rogan
show with this book it would go crazy
you know i was broke when i went on joe
rogan's show because joe rogan is the
one that this i this t-shirt came from
joe rogan really yeah this this is his
idea you know i went on the show and i
told joe [ __ ] show i'm [ __ ] up
i'm doing bad man i'm not hearing bad
and he was like you know what you need
and i was like what do i need joe
you need a t-shirt
i said oh
[ __ ] a t-shirt [ __ ] i need
something he thought
so when he said that one day i'm walking
down the street downtown la and this
this kid come up to me and he's like hey
man
i got an idea for you
white kid you know
what the [ __ ]
another one of these idea [ __ ]
right
and what you got kid
and you ought to do a t-shirt
i said oh no not another one of y'all to
myself you know i would never disrespect
anybody but you know i get to think
whatever i want to think
and i was like oh [ __ ] and i was like
what's your t-shirt idea he said
the real rick ross is not a rapper
i say corny ass [ __ ]
but not
then the kids say i'll do everything
i'll print it i'll design it and i'll do
all this and and i don't know that this
kid is one of the best [ __ ] graphic
artists in the world oh [ __ ] yeah i
didn't know that nice i [ __ ] love
that so i said you know let's do it man
so he did the shirt and a couple weeks
later he called me hey man i got some
shirts for you come take some pictures
so i go down and take some pictures in
the shirt and
he throws me a hundred of them
i was like huh
these are mine he's like yeah those are
yours
[ __ ] okay i'm gonna sell these [ __ ]
for five dollars and i get on the street
and
people start giving me 20 bucks for them
man yeah um
i took you right back to that first rock
i throw all of them in one day
yeah i know what to do with this [ __ ]
it's
what it's different about selling
clothes [ __ ] it's it's like having [ __ ]
like well i have this much stuff i got
to get rid of it if i get rid of it at
30 the rest is profit let's go that's
how i do with these clothes i stopped
selling weed start selling clothes man
same thing it's just like how can i do i
got 24 bands in this i need to break it
down at this price bubble it's drug drug
math is the ultimate math i say every
[ __ ] episode any math we do gets
translated to pounds and then comes back
to what we're talking about with him
yeah the only way to do it it's all the
same it's the same
same thing for everything of business
yeah so that t-shirt uh
should i go on joe rogan's show
joe joe takes me back on the show that
was my last time coming on the show
two episodes right yeah two episodes he
takes the t-shirt and he puts the [ __ ]
on
good [ __ ] i remember that he puts the
[ __ ] shirt on on camera
breaks my [ __ ] paypal mmm nice
paypal goals good [ __ ] bananas like
two days later paypal go banana had to
verify you and everything still they
thought i was [ __ ] scared of scamming
you at first
they shut that [ __ ] down
wouldn't let us take the money out
good problem to have i took that and we
moved in our first apartment you know
and uh
[ __ ] i went on tour with that t-shirt
and everything and then
they did a fair factor commercial and
joe rogan had on this
t-shirt in the [ __ ] commercial man
that's [ __ ] because he loved his
t-shirt because i used really good
quality cotton that is that's i said i'm
going to use good quad that's a good
move on him that's [ __ ] awesome
that's like what he's talking about like
putting out good vibes to people just
looking out just without even
asking
you know it wasn't what i wanted no but
you know it was it was a good spark
something else like wait how much i sell
these for and then the kid hit you up
like maybe i need a shirt
see things came back to you for a reason
man you got your first apartment bam
right back it did you know and that
that's that put me on my way that
enabled me to to publish my first book
and help me publish this book well
here's your first one come out
this book yeah it's about my life no
what year did the first one come out i
don't know that book been out about
seven years now i can't remember so yeah
that that's the one when i first before
we started starting yeah yeah yeah this
is the one you bought first yeah this
one here just came out like a year ago
okay this is the 21 key success this is
the one where he was writing it down
yeah yeah man what a [ __ ] that's a
story in itself right there oh no that's
another movie you know he was there when
when the marshals kicked us out my mom's
house
you know they kicked us out my mom's
house why
because she used to took one of those
crazy ass loans you know those loans uh
those predatory loans
so when i got home her house know was
like 3 200 a month and she was 45
thousand dollars behind
so when you come out you don't get to
keep any of this money all the money you
ever made is called they snatch it from
you instantly right i was [ __ ] up when
i got home
that's [ __ ] even
even if it was through a legal cut say
you bought a company is illegal they
take all of it it don't matter you know
what my mom used to say a fool in his
money would soon depart
so that's a good thing i like that
but when you got some sense money will
come to you
[Laughter]
there's another before we finish though
when you read this article you're going
to see you know like
why i'm in the boxing
because oh yeah when he came to jail i
told him i was going to be in the boxing
so that's how what's your what's your
box is it a company is this what you're
doing or is it just
i got a kid named kid austin he right
now he's my biggest prospect i believe
that he is going to read he's going to
redo boxing he's going to make more
money than floyd mayweather he
hey you you know you know money and you
know how to spot things so if you're
saying that damn
kid austin where's he from
uh austin texas oh okay i just thought
maybe his name that's his name kid
austin nice man so you're can you put
him up legally in in in the boxing arena
now oh yeah i'm gonna be the king of
boxing i ain't just in boxing i'm going
to take boxing over
that's how i get the best kid in boxing
i mean house what else you get the best
kid for you know like
uh how's he
he just turned 19. getting ready
damn
he's that young and he's already doing
this here he's got his 54k death was
[ __ ] big
you see him
is that him yeah it's just him right
here
oh yeah that's his page
damn he's only night about to be 19.
yeah just turning 19. a grown ass man
already and he wants to fight every week
he enjoys it well you know what he don't
think anybody can hit him
really he's been hit yet
i think he's saying got hit one time
that he remembered
yeah he said they can't hit him man yo
look at that [ __ ] picture that looks
like i put that on a shirt god damn put
that on a shirt right there for real
that's good
you got a shirt company let's do it that
shirt yeah we put that shirt on a
picture on the shirt i don't know if my
audience is all weed it's all weed
hold on
give me five minutes and i can i can i
can figure something
a chance you didn't have a chance my man
that's a big kid he's 19 years old and
that's how big this guy is
how do you feel about all the celebrity
boxing matches
i mean uh
it's all entertainment yeah you know uh
wwf at that point i i was talking to i'm
talking to another another boxer right
now uh anthony peterson who who was
one of the greats you know he's 38 and
one and the one loss that he has the guy
could have been on us on steroids he got
caught steroid about three or four
months later but anyway
and the way he he broke it down to me is
you know because i i look at boxing as a
violent sport
of course in my personal opinion it's a
violent sport and i got in it to to to
help the fighters
so really really reason i'm in the
boxing is to help the fighters not to to
enrich myself
that's all i mean i will get enriched
you know yeah i mean it's just that's
just the law of
the law of the universe
if you
constantly put something in
something's gonna come out reciprocation
you know like if you're putting good
[ __ ] in good vibes good vibes come out
you put shitty vibes you know they say
live by the gun die by the gun so law of
attraction we just talked about that
yeah we preach this [ __ ] all the time
the law of attraction yeah i believe in
the law of attraction so real like
i don't know we we we got gotta we gotta
get together again but we can go into so
much so much [ __ ]
uh uh but i found out that
i put myself in prison
because before i'd ever been a police
car i had enough money to quit selling
dope
but i didn't
and i would be laying in bed
with one of my girls and i would be like
hey when i go to jail you going to run
um so
a logical thinking person
would be like
i got enough money
why not quit before i go to jail
yeah but me
i was saying
are you going to run for me when i go to
jail
you're manifesting it so i already knew
i was going to jail yeah he manifested
yourself going straight so i manifested
myself in jail and once i got to prison
and i figured that out
i started manifesting myself out of
prison
and when you when you do that what
happens is your mind start to make you
do the things that it takes to get the
results that you need
and and that's why i learned how to read
you know that's why i learned how to use
a law library shepherd eyes and i knew
all the top jailhouse lawyers you know
they were they became my best friends
you know we ate at the same table
you know i snuck food to him
you know
you you you find yourself
catering to these situations
that
will put you in a position to accomplish
the goals that you're trying to
accomplish
i love that did you read the secret the
book the secret i read the secret yeah
he just talked about that i read 300
books
oh wow why are you just sitting there
300 bucks 300 i used to read maybe
some weeks three books a week wow
did you represent yourself when you got
out i didn't uh i had a public defender
i found the issue he put it together hmm
did he look at you like was he [ __ ]
jean astounded when you broke it down to
him
he didn't believe it at first
yeah nobody nobody really
it took a while before people really
dug into it you know like
i had to explain to them kind of like
what i did to you guys like a guy could
wake up this morning you know and be
like [ __ ] i see these kids out here
making all that [ __ ] money my kid
needs surgery i'm going out and get some
of it
you know and uh
and go get the money you know
so i had to break it down to him like
that and that's the way he wrote the
brief up to the appeals court
you know that a guy can't become a
career criminal in one day you know
there's no way you're a career criminal
and you only commit a crime one day it's
not possible and and and the way i when
i found out the way the law read is that
it's a continuous criminal spree so a
spree could go for a day
it could go for 10 years
but it's still one spree
one hell of a spree
but the way you word it that's [ __ ]
true yeah that is completely true that's
what it is okay a continuous criminal
spree it's not interrupted
now if it gets interrupted by jail now
you know you're in the wrong
now your career criminal going back
because that's what i'm saying jail's
there to re rehabilitate
i'd be sitting there still i would have
never thought of that but i i can do
stuff like that it's like
even out here on the streets you know
like i can take situations and i can
analyze them and and
and put things together and just make
you know
it's crazy like like right now man it's
it's like i'm in a position of like
[ __ ] bananas you know like i know
like six billionaires you know like
[ __ ] these guys
take my phone call you know like i can
go to their places you know and and have
a conversation with them and i never
knew that before
so
now my only thing is to put the play
together
you're on your way
what i see is you have like a hyper
focus in your brain from
going to tennis
and that's all you did you didn't even
get in trouble you weren't doing nothing
you were just going to bed i was a
square you're hyper because you were so
focused on tennis right yeah
and then what you get into the the cars
you're like well i'm gonna make 300 a
night
then you you and then i have my own chop
shop
then you're selling drugs and literally
making a billion dollars
and then you're in prison i need to get
out and you find a way to get out and
now i'm going to take over boxing so i
can't wait to see the next couple years
but i can't even read and i need to get
out and then you have to teach yourself
right so far
from getting out
yeah that's remarkable i just i want the
fans to wrap their minds around that's
what i'm trying to like at the end of
this that take that we're in a [ __ ] up
predicament in life
that read that they got to read that
article because jesse did his research
yo we're going to link that and i'm
going to link these and any other uh
websites you're trying to follow me on
instagram too freeway ricky i'll put all
that right when you facebook twitter
did you tell us about your wheat brand
at all that's our audience i think yeah
that's our main oh yeah target focus oh
yeah yeah everybody open my dispensary
up are you
yeah i got a dispensary oh [ __ ] i
thought you were just doing the brand
like selling this spot i know i wanted
to switch me
oh wow and i gotta and i gotta grow too
i'm building a forty four thousand
square foot grow where you open san
bernardino oh [ __ ]
i can show you the pictures of the girl
i got to grow right here nice like buy
needles and [ __ ]
no san bernardino oh okay okay because i
have a lot of homies out there san
bernardino baby nice what do you think
about opening the shop at
uh the shop is gonna be in uh
the shop is gonna be in
uh
well i just hit 251 000 followers good
[ __ ] quarter mil
uh the shop is gonna be in sun valley
south valley where's that at
uh northern l.a right right around here
not far from here you ready to come and
get some weed from me i'm had the
cheapest wheat in town that's the way to
go though because i'm not gonna uh i'm
not gonna be trying to double my money
no no if you can make 15 to 30 off of
off of an eighth and somebody can buy it
at 30 they're gonna come back three
times a week
then buy that eighty dollar eight one of
my they've got a picture of of some of
my weed
l.a kingpins that's one of my brands you
know i got like five brands i didn't
know that i just thought it was the
freeway ricky one oh no i got about five
brands what what are the bridges with
all the big dogs
oh i got you okay okay because i've seen
the one where it looks like a straight
scarface cover yeah that's that's that's
that's what the cure company yeah okay
so it is with over here you know what i
do is is what happens is when i go when
i go to those companies and i be wanting
to buy weed from them
oh we don't want to sell you eat
but we'll do a brand with you
take it and i'd be like oh yeah get that
you're playing right into my clutches
yeah you can make a little bit here a
little bit there simultaneously you did
better you did better everybody
stay away from me
if you allow me to
oh that got my building right here
that's my building right there
oh [ __ ] that's an industrial space man
oh you're already building out yeah
forty four thousand square feet this
place is gonna make like
every yeah i would say every harvest
yeah we looking to do like 1600 pounds
every two months yeah no matter what and
at base 2300 out the door even in bulk
where you put it in the bags you know oh
yeah you just put in the branded bag
maybe it's 26 out the door
that they go to that freeway there it is
right there that's that's what's up
nice man i love that's that's the one
i've seen i didn't know you had other
brands
yeah it's got another brand that i'm
doing with some guys out of humboldt
called uh
yayo
y-a-y-o yes yes
yes uh then i got another brand that i'm
doing with uh a company out of
sacramento uh leaf
i think life
leafly is it leafly yeah that's a huge
website yeah it's a big it's a big one
not the website not lethally not leafly
this company used to grow for cookies
and and they they big they got a hundred
and sixty thousand square foot
[ __ ]
so and they grow some of this so what
you're doing is good though you're going
out there going hey you guys do all the
work right
you do all the work right
and you just get give me money it's it's
good because while you're asleep you're
getting paid every day and then i just
signed a deal in connecticut
damn i'm signing another deal in
oklahoma with my edibles uh i'm gonna do
with uh
chef joey out of out of oklahoma my
edibles oklahoma's wild wild west right
now um
what whatever suggest just do the
highest milligrams you can do
on the edibles over there yeah and
they'll sell faster yeah because over
here it's a hundred
and you know my stuff gonna be cheap too
not just
i want great product at a cheap price
that's the way that's the way you get
everybody though so
well you got to wait
i ain't gonna tell y'all what i'm gonna
do for my grand opening otherwise
everybody gonna try to copy me don't say
it don't say it so i ain't gonna tell
them but my grand opening you better be
there you're gonna miss out on a treat
treat treat treatment
hey i'm enticing what the [ __ ] yeah
y'all gotta come
where's that going to be you said or at
some point
yeah yeah how long how long do you think
uh we hoping to be open by november oh
[ __ ] i'm gonna have no fancy place i
ain't going to have you used to this
shop you need a [ __ ] four walls don't
look like a trap house that's fine
that's what i might call it a trap house
that's fine putting it in [ __ ] looks
like it's boarded up outside you walk in
it's actually nice that'd be [ __ ]
that's kind of tried actually right nice
papers on the windows and i'm gonna have
weed everybody's weed i want everybody's
week just like when i sold
on the black market i wanted everybody's
weed i want king lily and everybody to
sell weed bring me your weed
all the weed i could afford
[ __ ] it you're someone's gonna buy it
there's a market for everything exactly
everybody and they want different
products you know some people don't want
cookies some want this one some don't
freeway you know
give them different states two different
price points you know what man you say
got to give the people
give the people what they want
that's true you live by that you're
gonna be good you know the richest
people i know live by that right
all my homies they got stacked money
live at that rule i'm gonna be one of
your homies with stack money yeah like i
said i'm gonna get mine away though i'm
gonna i'm gonna do an office for charity
that's good though man you you've
already learned all the mistakes you had
the first time
and then you know with kid we just
signed uh a deal with uh with davey
entertainment
you know um they they giving the girl
who the black wrestler did you see that
she was the first black forever winner
of wrestling in the olympics in the
olympics gold medal i watched the
olympics i didn't see that oh yeah i did
see her yeah i saw her she looked mad uh
like like a really nice kid and then she
you know what i mean when you see those
girls you're like oh you probably she
was like nerd she was buff right
i just watched the whole trial all of
this i know exactly which girl you're
talking about so what what baby is doing
she said you know she said
now i want to go metal buy my mama a
food truck because her mom's food truck
got burned up
and the fire didn't have insurance on it
and uh
so
cam'ron from davis entertainment
uh cruz kitchen he was like
girl 30 thousand dollars ain't gonna get
you no food truck
i'm gonna donate you one oh [ __ ] nice he
donated the truck to her that's the same
company that kid is with
oh so he's just signed to them yeah yeah
we signed him to him as we didn't sign
him to a boxing promoter you know i
didn't want it to be just regular boxing
i wanted to be more entertainment you
know like look man you you got more than
just you more than just a boxer
you know boxing is for like just
i mean you know you could be smart in
box too you know i think sugar ray was
pretty smart he was smart i think
anybody that's making that kind of money
just by using their body is smart i
don't care if they're not intellectually
smart it's kind of tough though you know
when you look at it you know
you're making money for beating people's
brains out
it's kind of brutal it's brutal after
taking breaks and taking the damage is
really what i would be worried about
exactly i mean you listen to most of the
boxers yeah and they talk
and it's a little slow
i get it it's not worth the sacrifice i
would never like i said how would you
take a shot from mike tyson like no
amount of money in the world yeah
because he might exactly [ __ ] me up in
one shot exactly you may never you may
never live and spend it yeah a dime no
hell no it's not worth it so i mean the
same thing with kids you take a shot
from a kid a kid and knock you down i
don't want to take a shot from that guy
you show me and anywhere in my body i
don't get hit by him especially if they
get a clean shot you know like i'll
throw up
yeah they they practice hitting you in
certain places yeah to knock you don't
knock your wind out like i think it's
illegal to hit back but right here is
the spot i always see people drop the
kids
they wanna they wanna hit that kidney if
they hit that kidney that kidney is shut
down and when the kidneys shut down
you're going down
so they get paid enough for doing their
thing because nobody don't
they don't no no
no no the only boxers i ever seen these
people was making so much money so
that's the only oh floyd mayweather i
don't watch boxing really so that's like
i hear about these guys like someone so
made
jake paul
that's entertaining entertainment i get
that that's what it should be i get it
it should be entertainment you know it
needs to go back to where it's
entertainment and the guys who are
taking all the punishment and doing all
the work should get all the money you
know and the guys who are sitting in
those big fat offices the promoters and
the managers should get very small money
you know you're not getting hit in the
head you know not running all the ufc
does a lot of evil [ __ ] like this yeah
so that's why i'm in the boxing
good man i can't wait to see that
bring it back and i mean i've been
watching the past couple years but my
mom's a boxing fan so that's why i grew
up seeing it guys got to come out to
take one of kids fights and and check
him out man you just let us know i'm
down i'm down i've never been to a
boxing i've never been to a fight i've
never been anything
and man you could do a wee shirt
was
a wee shirt marijuana give me 10 minutes
and i should come up with something i
come up with a design i can go with the
design all right well you heard it here
all right you heard it here first
i can come up with something better than
joe rogan did joe rogan told me to do
the shirt bro
i will make it and you're gonna make
this yeah i got you i got you that's the
deal yeah don't worry i think of it all
up and then someone could draw it all
right let's do it i got it i need a i
need a great weed shirt so i can wear to
the dispensaries when i got you easy no
no that's that's that's my that's right
up my alley man let's do it yeah i'm
down
all right so uh we'll we'll link all
your stuff all your socials and
everything where can people find the
books then get at my website don't go to
amazon don't go to amazon no i ain't
gonna sign if you buy from amazon don't
go to amazon if you buy from my website
i will sign and autograph it and
with an autographed copy you get to come
to the on a thousand party right when i
set a hundred thousand i'm gonna throw
this big party nice yes see you're on
the marketing tip already you know only
people can come if you have that
i don't care if you got a million
dollars
you can't get in the door
if you don't have autographed copy
that's going to be my rule and i ain't
going to change
nice man
i love it i love it so what's the
website
freeway
ricky ross
so freewayrickyross.com have that linked
in the uh in the description guys for
every single social he's got we have a
link in the description so if you're on
spotify apple google whatever you're on
youtube it'll be in the description
thank you i appreciate it give me some
time
i have that shirt i can think of
something tight let's do it i'm ready
for it i need it i'm
i've been trying to come up with a good
weed shirt i got it i that's what i do
man so just give me a little bit of time
i can think of something to hide all
right yeah we got something i'll get
something maybe that 250 000 followers i
got might buy one
that's the whole point man that social
media just pumps everything
it's the best part of 250 000 buyers
shirt times 20. you can imagine that
oh yeah that's in that shirt right now i
can do it right now i can do that math
real quick
all right let me go get something to eat
yeah thank you so much i appreciate it
uh you guys thank you so much for
hanging out this has been freeway rick
ross appreciate you so much worth the
drive thank you so much for coming out
late too appreciate it i know it's late
but thank you so much no doubt oh ho oh
have a dope best day guys sorry i didn't
even do the outro this has been another
episode of the dope as usual podcast i'm
dope psyola have a dope ass day so i got
caught up i'm literally i'm trying to
think of all the designs in my head
[Music]
perfect perfect
[Music]